hello there reject nation I'm Greg Alba
with the lovely and talented and funny
Stacey Stacey before we go and do this
video from what culture tell them about
the Maltin event
do I have to whisper like here - no no
I'm sorry I'm excited to be working on
the film festival coming up May 10th
through 12th at the Egyptian theater
lawton fast legendary film critic and
family man Leonard Maltin alarm Jessie
Moulton and Alice Moulton team this guy
knows everyone he knows every film this
is a festival for hidden gems films you
may not have seen before maybe you
didn't get their due this is for
cinephiles for film fanatics film nerds
it's not like an industry film festival
it's not sudden dance people Breyers ice
cream bar whatever they do know this is
really just for film films fans send
Hollywood to get your tickets weakened
badges are on sale right now at Leonard
Maltin calm / Moulton fest so please
join us for the weekend you're gonna
have feature films shorts documentaries
TV shows receptions all kinds of fun
stuff paintings art it's gonna be packed
full of everything for an incredible
price so we're so excited to have people
join us gonna be a good time yeah also
special guests like Joe Dante and Doug
Benson and Holly Payne and incredible
lineup of people that we will announce
Oh Doug Benson I I smoked crack oh you
smoked crack yeah we have our starting a
podcast together yeah that's what he's
known for right yeah he's a big
crackhead let's watch this video for
more culture eight horror movies he
didn't know we're connected what's
hopping in this now shall we do let's do
it I'm excited
what cultures one of my favorite channel
Stacey I'm happy to see their stuff
terrifying universes yeah we'll see
various appearances horror movies it has
to be the Necronomicon Elbert ickey
created by writer HP Lovecraft it wasn't
actually the first place that honor if
it can be pinpointed at all goes to the
Haunted palace with Vincent Price in
appeared later in the Dunwich horror
also equinox and versions of the
Necronomicon have been ceded throughout
the
[Music]
[Music]
honestly with such and tested methods
I have one I made my son who gets
uncomfortable when I incidentally they
also share one key knotty point they
both contain RJ McCready McCready is the
protagonist of the research mission
undertaken in the thing at the end of
the movie McCready space he was child's
watching that vicinity gunned down in
the middle of the freezing Antarctic it
seems that James go and wanted to have
some fun with carpenters movie including
the RJ McCready auctioneers and Funeral
Home in a sly reference to slit this
infamous inspiration in this universe we
can assume Akriti didn't survive and has
had a lovely funeral home named
afternoon did play by character
infection yeah I remember
trusted I showed in the naughty
defibrillation see what make sense
either way to have a funeral parlor bold
considering another expedition six
Creepshow I'm Jason goes to hell are
they really
he's his basement that bounty hunter
giucose to investigate is not only the
original Necronomicon from the Evil Dead
series but also and the steer is great
emblazoned with Arctic expedition Juliet
it's not just ready that Jason likes to
hang out with the crate is the same one
from Stephen King's Creepshow one
terrifying reality we're smashing
villains and creepy creatures roam
freely
either that or Jason is just quite a
collector of horror film artifacts in
between stabbing people to death they
seize on Brian
v Silent Hill and Village of the Damned
it's like really connected though really
freaks me out when the fire burns up her
vagina and like rip surprise underage
children and unusual deaths begin to
occur in their wake
surprise surprise it's of course the
weird Whitehead who fingered completely
on our pathetic children that are doing
it
Silent Hill also has some weird
supernatural goings-on with italics
which is between normal and plagued by a
dark transformation with the elementary
school named after the very same
location information that dad oh really
so this is the scene as in the past
Silent Hill he does event with a bunch
of gray ghosts like children if you
needed more convincing oh they even look
what they're burning
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
what I'm most impressed by I haven't
even seen is exaggerated but realistic
movie to make a brief cameo and it's a
fun little nod to the directors past
work three revenues and hailing a small
link between the two horror movies and
news what is the connection between a
world inhabited by transformative mod
lies and vicious werewolves when you
think about it it does make sense they
both turn into destructive masters in
the dead of night very what makes this
connection all the more appealing is
that the news report itself is a
fictional character named new Landis
hide by Juma crab combining the two
movies is a given place up to the idea
that the moon might have more
transformative powers than we think in
director Joe Dante
who's gonna be at the malted event the
warning before it's too late - right
Chucky just about every other Smasher
ever if you have a taste of spooky
movies it's likely a certain evidence
Locker in Bride of Chucky will the court
you're right that's full of every
possible horror movie franchises Jason
the chainsaw from Texas Chainsaw
Massacre that's cool people live like
usual but still it's almost kind of sad
a collection of slashes beaten and
rendered nothing more than the most
memorable parts if that wasn't enough
meta commentary also makes the right
comment - why does that look so familiar
when launching an air bag full of nails
into a man's head such a detective is
the protagonist of the movie and comes
into ownership of the configuration
early on a continuation of the reference
perhaps he could be the one behind such
a collection one hook having in the
woods and faculty faculty specifically
references Easter eggs and replications
of classic scary movies
years it's pretty surprising that the
cabin in the woods has one more sneaky
link that makes sense to put into the
context of endure this up or what a
horror as were introduced to the
organization running America's
sacrificial actually is to keep the
world safe citizen and hardly discuss
that success rates commenting please we
haven't had a glitch since 98
and what's horror film that fits the
necessary trophy came out in 1998 that's
right the weird school alien invasion
movie with Elijah Wood the faculty also
set in the US the film can be considered
the glitch in their system since none of
the kids die
that procedure failing to collect the
correct sacrifices from the fool the
athlete for the attention by due to a
homemade drug concocted by the scholar
it also explains happy to be taught that
in ninety days it was the candy
apartments for two good message between
these films really is that drugs are
freaking cool are taken little means
that you won't get murdered which is a
nice set aside stay in school guys but
still snort that line it is good and
that's a list what are the horror movies
are not so secretly connected share your
findings in the comment section below
I mean Arshad this has been what culture
make sure to subscribe to the water
culture YouTube channel for more let's
like this
that was neat yeah that was neat I mean
some of these I'm like are they really
connected or is that just like the
negative she's kind of similar
yeah like the Necronomicon ex mortis
yeah that's like a reoccurring motif I'd
say something that it's been passed out
in several of the horror movies but is
that really like oh they're connected
now you know what I mean so it's kind of
confusing to me
to me I was expecting more of like you
know how like Tarantino has said Michael
Madsen's oh yeah that their brother yeah
yeah I'd be like oh it's the same
character or anything but it's just like
kind of making references to other films
or if there's like a similar yeah
exactly something cuz like with the
thing and that reference that James Gunn
threw in with the with the funeral home
I'm like yeah that could have just been
a reference you know that he just put in
there but does that mean that it's
actually a connected film at that point
where something is obviously they
flashed the image at the end of predator
2 when you see the alien skull showing
oh [ __ ] the Alien and Predator movies
are connected yeah I forgot I didn't
recall him remember any of that Bride of
Chucky like to me the Silent Hill one
that seems like really connect yeah
Village of the Damned like then they
were pointing all those things and I
always thought there was like oh there's
some like references or kind of like
those are the Damned in here but then
the way they were talking about her
really dissecting it that was pretty
cool to me like damn that's really it
does seem like it's possibly connected
to though as I thought it would be like
quotes here to really establish their
connections or something like that it's
all how you interpret it the one that I
actually thought was really cool was the
frozen and hatchet to one and I haven't
seen for that movie I've seen either of
those movies yet that was the one that
was the most clear right oh these are
definitely connected yeah because the
same universe because there's the girl
on the TV yeah with it with the name
there and everything and the gremlins
and the witch was the other one at
gremlins and the howling that was
something that was like oh that's pretty
neat to the the same reporter but then
again I thought it just kind of been
like a typecasting like I was watching
there's there's the the new curse of
yeah
I don't know I say I'm Spanish the
cursive la la Arona and there's in the
movie there's a guy who plays a priest
and then in the Annabelle movie he also
plays a priest and this is like very
similar character so people are trying
to decipher like are they connected to
the contouring universe or not but in my
mind I'm like no I just he's just
probably playing a priest again or
something like that you know I kind of
rewatched some of these or watch them
for the first time yeah have you seen
any of them no no I never who knows
there's a few of those like I haven't
seen frozen I actually haven't seen the
faculty which I've heard is like what
very watchable oh do then we was amazing
dude check it out dude I grew up on that
movie did you did you know yeah my
parents were not that censor me very
well those guys watch HBO at a very
young age
oh man yeah I started doing porn when I
was 13 oh well what do you got yeah what
do you got on now I was directing porn
at 11 so that's actually kind of
impressive you know I mean being
important as opposed to directing a
porno is a very different magic I mean
nowadays with the internet like you got
to make your own stuff you know you have
to create your own content and brand and
you know you can't just be the star
anymore like you got it I mean if my
channel ever fails I'm finding I'm just
becoming a webcam model I feel like I
got the body for it I feel like if I was
in a jam if I was in a really tight spot
like I could be a webcam girl yeah like
any girl good yeah just wear a mask I
swear I mask so my dad find out what if
your dad wants Tomic thanks to our
culture for your video you can subscribe
to the reject nation click that
notification bell Maltin event go check
it out today yeah the best fest that's
what's called yes I'm sorry
text Leonard later